SAVE PLANET EARTH.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOININGS YOU.
AC 360 STARTS NOW.
>>> GOOD EVENING.
THE JURY IN THE CASES OF THE
THREE WHITE MEN CHARGED IN THE
KILLING OF AN UNARMED BLACK MAN,
AHMAUD ARBERY, JUST WRAPPED UP
ITS FIRST DAY OF DELIBERATION.
IT'S ONE OF THREE CASES WE'RE
FOCUSED ON THIS EVENING.
ALL HAVE CAPTURED THE ATTENTION
OF AMERICANS ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
AND DELVE INTO ISSUES OF EITHER
RACE OR FAR-RIGHT EXTREMISM.
AND ALSO, IMPORTANTLY, WHETHER
WE'RE TOO DIVIDED AS A NATION TO
AGREE ON AN APPROPRIATE
DEFINITION OF THE WORD JUSTICE.
I'M JOHN BERMAN, IN FOR
ANDERSON.
WE WILL GET TO THE MEN CHARGED
FOR KILLING AHMAUD ARBERY IN A
MOMENT BUT WE BEGIN WITH
BREAKING NEWS ON A PAIR OF LEGAL
CASES THAT INVOLVE A VIOLENT
RIGHT WING EXTREMISM IN THIS
COUNTRY'S RECENT HISTORY.
FIRST, IN CHARLOTTESVILLE,
VIRGINIA, WHERE A PARTIAL
VERDICT WAS ANNOUNCED JUST HOURS
AGO IN A CIVIL CASE BROUGHT
AGAINST SOME OF THOSE INVOLVED
WITH THAT 2017 UNITE THE RIGHT
RALLY THAT LEFT ONE WOMAN,
HEATHER HEYER, DEAD.
IN A MOMENT, WE'LL HEAR REACTION
FROM HER MOTHER.
FIRST, THOUGH, CNN'S ELLE REEVE
JOINS US NOW.
ELLE, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THE VERDICT?
>> Reporter: WELL, THE JURY WAS
HUNG ON THE QUESTION OF FEDERAL
CONSPIRACY CHARGES RELATING TO A
LAW PASSED IN THE 1870s TO FIGHT
THE KKK BUT THEY DID FIND THESE
GUYS LIABLE UNDER A VIRGINIA
CONSPIRACY LAW.
AND THAT'S REALLY INTERESTING
BECAUSE THEY -- THE OTHER
DEFENDANTS TOOK GREAT PAINS TO
SAY THEY NEVER HAD ANY CONTACT
WITH JAMES ALEX FIELDS, WHO IS
CONVICTED OF FIRST-DEGREE MURDER
FOR DRIVING HIS CAR INTO A CROWD
AND KILLING HEATHER HEYER.
HE IS SERVING A LIFE SENTENCE.
WHAT IT MEANS IS THAT THE JURY
FINDS THAT, AT LEAST IN SOME
PART, THE LEADERS OF THE GROUP
WHO GLAMORIZED VIOLENCE OR
PLANNED FOR IT AT THE EVENT ARE,
IN SOME WAY, RESPONSIBLE FOR
THOSE WHO CAME TO THE EVENT AND
PARTICIPATED IN THAT VIOLENCE.
>> AND, ELLE, I SHOULD NOTE YOU
WERE THERE THAT NIGHT.
YOU WERE THERE IN 2017.
YOU ARE THERE NOW TO SEE THIS
JURY'S DECISION ON THIS.
AND THERE IS A LOT OF MONEY AT
PLAY.
A LOT OF MONEY.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT?
>> Reporter: THERE IS.
SO, THERE ARE TWO PARTS OF
THAT -- OF THAT WEEKEND.
THERE WAS A TORCH MARCH, WHICH
HAD NO PERMIT.
AND THERE WAS A RALLY, WHICH DID
HAVE A PERMIT.
THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE
TORCH MARCH ARE BEING HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT MORE MONEY
THAN THOSE THAT DID NOT.
ANOTHER STRANGE THING IS THAT ON
THE CONSPIRACY CHARGE -- AND
THAT'S THE ONE THAT HITS ALL THE
DEFENDANTS -- THEY'VE AWARDED
VERY LOW NUMBERS FOR
COMPENSATORY DAMAGES.
$1 OR $0.
BUT THEY AWARDED HALF A MILLION
OR A MILLION DOLLARS IN PUNITIVE
DAMAGES.
AND THE SUPREME COURT HAS HELD
THAT THE RATIO BETWEEN THOSE TWO
HAS TO BE A LOT SMALLER, LIKE AT
MOST, ONE TO TEN.
AND SO, THAT MEANS THAT THE --
THE JUDGE WILL POSSIBLY HAVE TO
LOWER THAT TO -- FROM, YOU KNOW,
SIX FIGURES TO TWO OR THREE.
>> OH, THAT'S INTERESTING.
SO, THIS NUMBER COULD CHANGE.
THE TOTAL NUMBER IS OVER
$20 MILLION NOW, BUT THAT NUMBER
COULD BE BROUGHT DOWN
SUBSTANTIALLY.
WHICH IMPACTS, I SUPPOSE, MY
NEXT QUESTION, ELLE, WHICH IS,
IS IT LIKELY THIS CASE, THE
OUTCOME, WILL HAVE WHAT THE
PLAINTIFF'S SIDE WANTED HERE,
WHICH IS TO BE A DETERRENT FOR
WHITE SPUPREMACISTS ORGANIZING N
THE FUTURE?
>> WELL, IT CLEARLY SENDS A
MESSAGE THAT FOR PEOPLE WHO
EXPLICITLY CALL FOR VIOLENCE,
THERE COULD BE CONSEQUENCES IF
SOMEBODY IS INSPIRED BY THAT TO
DO IT.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
THIS CASE HAVE QUIT ORGANIZING.
RICHARD SPENCER SAYS HE HATES
THE ALT-RIGHT AND IT HATES HIM
BACK.
MATT HOEINBACH HAS BEEN TALKING
TO ME ABOUT THE LONG-TERM
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS.
DURING THIS TRIAL, HE GOT FIRED
FROM McDONALD'S BECAUSE SOMEONE
SAW HIM ON THE NEWS AND FIGURED
OUT THAT HE WAS A PROFESSIONAL
RACIST.
SO, YEAH, A LOT OF THESE GUYS
ARE OUT OF THE MOVEMENT BUT THE
OLD MONEY WHITE NATIONALISTS
BEHIND THE SCENES WHO FUNDED
THEM AND NUR THURED THEM, THEY
WEREN'T INVOLVED IN THIS CASE
AND SO THEY ARE SILL OUT THERE.
>> ELLE REEVE AS I SAID, YOU
WERE THERE IN 2017.
YOU ARE THERE TONIGHT.
I IMAGINE THERE WILL BE MORE
CHAPTERS IN THE FUTURE YOU WILL
BE COVERING AS WELL.
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU ARE
DOING ON THIS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AS WE MENTIONED, ONE WOMAN
WAS KILLED DURING THAT 2017
RALLY.
HER NAME WAS HEATHER HEYER.
A 32-YEAR-OLD PAY LA LEGAL.
SHE WAS KILLED WHEN ONE OF THE
DEFENDANTS DROVE HIS CAR INTO A
CROWD OF COUNTER-PROTESTORS.
THAT MAN IS NOW SERVING MULTIPLE
LIFE SENTENCES.
WE ARE HONORED THAT HEATHER'S
MOTHER, SUSAN, COULD JOIN US
TONIGHT.
SUSAN, VERY NICE TO SEE YOU.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US.
WHEN YOU HEARD WHAT THE JURY
DECIDED TODAY, WHAT WENT THROUGH
YOUR MIND?
>> WELL, MY FIRST QUESTION WAS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
WERE NOT CONVICTED ON -- ON ONE
AND TWO AND IT TOOK A WHILE TO
PARSE OUT THAT THAT WAS FEDERAL
RELATED.
BUT, YEAH, I -- I WAS GLAD THE
JURY WAS ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
I MEAN, EVEN WHEN THE EVIDENCE
SEEMS VERY CLEAR, YOU CAN'T
ALWAYS DETERMINE WHAT A JURY IS
GOING TO SAY OR DO.
UM, SO I WAS GLAD THEY WERE ABLE
TO RECOGNIZE THE PREPONDERANCE
OF THE EVIDENCE DEFINITELY
SHOWED THE CLIENTS TO BE GUILTY
AND THE EVIDENCE WAS THEIR OWN
WORDS.
THAT WAS THE BEAUTY OF THE CASE.
THAT INTEGRITY FOR AMERICA SPENT
A GREAT DEAL OF TIME FINDING THE
DEFENDANTS' OWN WORDS TO USE IN
THE CASE.
>> THIS PARTIAL VERDICT, AND
OBVIOUSLY THE PREVIOUS-CRIMINAL
TRIAL OF JAMES FIELDS, JR., DOES
THIS FEEL LIKE ENOUGH
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR YOU?
IS THIS WHAT JUSTICE, IN YOUR
MIND, LOOKS LIKE?
>> I GUESS.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE EVER FEEL
JUSTICE IN A MURDER CASE.
THIS IS THE FIRST -- AND GOD
KNOWS, I HOPE THE ONLY MURDER IN
MY LIFE.
UM, I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU EVER
FEEL COMPLETE JUSTICE.
BUT I -- I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE
COULD BE DONE.
I THINK THAT, UM, THIS SPEAKS
VOLUMES TO TRYING TO SET THINGS
STRAIGHT.
>> TRYING TO SET THINGS
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU HOPE THAT
PEOPLE TAKE AWAY FROM THE JURY'S
DECISION TODAY IN TERMS OF ANY
LARGER MESSAGE ABOUT WHAT IS AND
ISN'T ACCEPTABLE IN THIS
COUNTRY?
>> WELL, THE -- THE DEFENDANTS
SEEM TO WANT TO ARGUE THAT THEIR
SPEECH WAS PROTECTED BY FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
AND I WOULD SAY, SPEECH IS
PROTECTED.
ACTION FROM THAT SPEECH IS NOT
SO, WHEN YOU SPEAK AND YOU,
YOURSELF, AND OTHERS ACT ON THAT
SPEECH, IT IS NO LONGER
PROTECTED.
UM, YOU KNOW, IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE
I'VE OFTEN SAID THINK BEFORE YOU
SPEAK.
SO, YEAH, DEFINITELY IN THIS
CASE.
>> WHAT ABOUT HEALING AND COMING
TOGETHER?
>> WITH WHO?
I MEAN, THOSE OF US WHO WERE NOT
DOING THE HATE SPEECH --
WE'RE -- WE'RE COMING TOGETHER,
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT
WE COULD HAVE A MEETING OF MINDS
ACROSS DIVIDING LINES BUT I'M
NOT HEARING ANY FORM OF
REPENTANCE OR SORRINESS FROM THE
DEFENDANTS IN THE CASE.
THEY SPENT MOST OF THE CASE KIND
OF JOVIAL -- JOVIALLY -- PARDON
MY WORD -- JOKINGLY PRESENTING
THEIR EVIDENCE IN THEIR DEFENSE.
AND UM, DIDN'T SHOW REMORSE.
SO, NO, I HAVE NO INTEREST IN
MAKING AMENDS WITH THOSE PEOPLE.
>> NO, AND THAT'S NOT WHAT I WAS
SUGGESTING AT ALL.
I WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT --
BELIEVE ME -- BELIEVE ME AND I
HEAR YOU I HEAR WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING THERE.
I WAS SPEAKING MORE ABOUT THE
DIVISIONS THAT WE ARE SEEING DAY
IN AND DAY OUT IN SOCIETY.
AND SORT OF, GIVING A SENSE OF
WHAT IS ACCEPTABLE AND NOT
ACCEPTABLE AND THIS JURY MAY
HAVE LAID DOWN A MARKER AND
SAID, THIS ISN'T RIGHT.
THAT BEING SAID, I WANT YOU TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT IS RIGHT.
I WANT YOU TO TALK ABOUT YOUR
DAUGHTER, HEATHER HEYER, FOR US.
JUST REMIND US WHO SHE WAS AND
WHAT YOU WANT HER LEGACY TO BE.
>> WELL, FIRST OFF, I NEED
PEOPLE TO STOP PUTTING HEATHER
ON A PEDESTAL.
SHE WAS A NORMAL 32-YEAR-OLD
FEISTY WOMAN.
UM, SHE HAD HER ROUGH EDGES JUST
LIKE ANYBODY.
AND SHE WAS A RANDOM MURDER IN A
MASS-CAR ATTACK.
SHE JUST HAPPENED TO BE THE ONE
THAT TOOK THE BRUNT FORCE AND IT
HIT HER AORTA AND HER ABDOMEN
AND BLED OUT IN FOUR PLACES.
SHE WAS NOT ASSASSINATED.
SHE WAS NOT A SAINT.
SHE WAS A NORMAL PERSON.
SO, WHAT I WANT YOU TO TAKE AWAY
FROM THAT IS STAND UP AND DO THE
RIGHT THING.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF
IMPACT THAT WILL HAVE.
UM, EVEN NOW, FOUR YEARS LATER,
I'M TALKING ON CNN AND AFTER
THIS, I'M -- BE TALKING TO SOME
INTERNATIONAL PRESS BECAUSE THE
IMPACT OF THAT ONE SMALL ACT HAS
BEEN FELT AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO CONGRATULATE
THE -- THE PLAINTIFFS IN THIS
CASE AND INTEGRITY FOR AMERICA.
WE WERE NOT PRIVY TO THE
TRIAL -- HEATHER, NOR THE
FOUNDATION.
BUT I STRONGLY SUPPORTED THE
CASE AND AM VERY PROUD OF THE
PLAINTIFFS FOR NOT BUCKLING
UNDER PRESSURE WHEN QUESTIONED
BY THE DEFENDANTS WHO WERE
ACTING AS THEIR OWN LAWYERS,
PARTICULARLY.
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND, THEY
WERE ANTAGONIZED AND PICKED AT A
BIT TO TRY TO MAKE THEM BREAK
DOWN OR LASH OUT AND THEY DID
NOT DO SO, SO I AM VERY PROUD OF
THEM.
>> SUSAN BROW, STAND UP AND DO
THE RIGHT THING.
>> YES.
>> AS A MESSAGE.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE I AM GETTING
FROM YOU TONIGHT.
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOU BEING
WITH US.
I APPRECIATE YOUR WORDS AND YOUR
GUIDANCE THROUGH THIS.
UM, BE WELL AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SPAENGIN SPEAKING TO YOU AGA.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> WE ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE FOUNDATION YOU MENTIONED
THAT YOU CREATED TO HONOR YOUR
DAUGHTER.
YOU CAN FIND DETAILS AT
HEATHERHEYER FOUNDATION.ORG.
>> NO --
>> SORRY, GO AHEAD.
>> DOT COM.
THAT WAS A MISTAKE MADE WHEN IT
WAS FORMED AND WE HAVE JUST KEPT
IT'S DOT COM, NOT DOT ORG.
>> WE WILL FIX IT RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE IT RIGHT ON